You know guys it seems like just yesterday the Overwatch League was first formed.
But after 4 stages, 23 weeks, and 91 days, I think it’s safe to say that the first ever OWL
season was a smashing success! Except for the 0-40 Shanghai Dragons thing.
But anyways... With the London Spitfire being your first ever champions.
we thought it’d be the perfect time take a look back,
and give you the Top 10 Plays from OWL Season 1.
Kicking off our list at number 10 is New York
Excelsior’s Libero, who goes on an absolute tear on Genji as he slices and dices his way
through not one, but 4 Seoul Dynasty players to fend off the oncoming siege.
(Casting)
Known as one of the world’s best battle Mercys, our number nine play sees Neptuno
prove that Mercy can do more than just save your team’s bacon.
With no DPS in sight, Neptuno took matters into his own hands and proceeded to wipe out
three Outlaws players, all while res’ing two of his teammates just for good measure.
(Casting)
Coming in at number 8 is the LA Gladiators’ Fissure on Kings Row, who lands an absolutely
disgusting 4-man earth shatter, before following it up with a triple collat firestrike to completely
wipe The Florida Mayhem.
(Casting)
If there’s one thing to take away from our number seven play, it’s that if at first
you don’t succeed, try try again.
With the game headed to overtime, Dallas’ OGE doesn’t let a blocked earth shatter
keep him down, as he recharges his ultimate in record-time to pull off one of the fastest
earth shatters you’ll ever see before capping it off with a 3k of his own.
(Casting)
Sneaking in at number 6 is New York Excelsior’s Pine, who slips behind enemy lines to pull
off a series of gutsy plays to delete 4 Spitfire players with flicks so filthy you’ll have
to watch them twice to believe them.
(Casting)
Jumping in at number 5 is yet another play from Fissure, who says - Who needs hitscan?
As he vaults through the air with primal rage to maul apart the deadly airborne duo that
known as “Pharmercy”.
Now can we all just take a minute to appreciate this man’s determination?
(Casting)
Number 4 on our list comes courtesy of one of the best McCree’s in the game, big boss
Pine.
Facing off against the Houston Outlaws on Ilios, Pine shows off his pin-point accuracy
as he pops off with a ridiculous 5k that only a big boss can pull off.
(Casting)
Coming in at number 3 on our list is Philadelphia Fusion’s Carpe who shows us that he can,
in fact, do it all, as he wipes out 4 members of the Boston Uprising with some crispy headshots
to retake the point and win the map.
(Casting)
Taking the runner up spot on our list, is a 2000 IQ team play for the ages.
A team play, that will go down as one of the best to ever be seen.
It’s the LA Gladiators surprising everyone on day 1 of the OWL playoffs.
So just sit back, relax, and enjoy the show.
(Casting)
the show.
In the OWL’s first Grand Final, London Spitfire’s Profit shows us why he is the best damn DPS
in the world.
With 23 seconds left on the clock, Profit cuts through the Fusion’s defense like a
knife through butter, single handedly deleting five players to go on and eventually win the
inaugural season of OWL
(Casting)
Alright guys that's our list, now if you like this video let us know in the comments.
And we might just give you another one.
"Another one."
Sorry that was a DJ Khaled reference, I'll stop now.
Thanks for watching. If you want more great content just like this, be sure to hit the subscribe button.